siguiendo los pasos de google y apple
amazon suspendió de su alojamiento web a
la red social partner por considerarla
un riesgo real para la seguridad pública
la plataforma popular entre el
movimiento de extrema derecha
estadounidense parece haber jugado un
papel central en la incitación al
violento asalto al capitolio de la
semana pasada para leer consiguió en los
últimos meses un aumento de seguidores
gracias a su falta de moderación de
contenido el reciente intento de frenar
el contenido más extremo de la
aplicación a través de un equipo de
voluntarios no terminó de convencer a
amazon publicaciones recientes llamaban
incluso al asesinato del vicepresidente
mike pence el ceo de partner refutó
estas acusaciones este fue un ataque
coordinado por los gigantes tecnológicos
para acabar con la competencia en el
mercado tuvimos demasiado éxito
demasiado rápido podrías esperar que
esta guerra por la competencia y la
libertad de expresión continúe pero no
cuenten con nosotros las principales
redes sociales han iniciado una política
más dura contra los discursos de odio y
el propio presidente de donald trump fue
expulsado de twitter partner se
autodenomina como la única
que protege el derecho constitucional a
la libertad de expresión apelando a
muchas de las voces conservadoras en
eeuu paralelas trabajo alguno de los
elementos más extremos que buscan
alternativas a las que llaman las
principales plataformas liberales el
servicio de alojamiento web de amazon
elimina un elemento clave para la
infraestructura de partner la red social
dijo que puede tomarle hasta una semana
reconstruirse y encontrar un proveedor
alternativo